It's a glimpse into the center of the Earth.
It's like listening to the heartbeat of the planet.
The physiological effects of being inside the volcano are significant...
...in that you have every force down there trying to kill you.
All right, so let's use the drone...
I wanted to share the Marum Crater...
...that's located in the island nation of Vanuatu by bringing a team with me...
...and documenting this place in a way that's never been seen.
The drone that we used is called the Phantom 2 Vision Plus.
We had also GoPros mounted onto these particular drones with gimbaled devices...
...so that no matter how much they shook, the video remains stable.
The greatest scientific value is just having videographic support...
...that can be used in tandem with other research that's happening in the world.
I really believe there's an opportunity...
...to merge those worlds of exploration and tech and then coming back...
...and reporting on all kinds of information that has not yet been discovered.